This is many of you will undoubtedly
remember.
It's the opening shot of Disney's beauty
and the beast.
At first glance,
it's colorful ballot and introduction of
main characters and plot points don't
seem to deviate too much from your
typical Disney movie.
We have her princess or young adult girl
who seeks some sort of fulfillment or
help element of magic evil forces
working against the princess or prince
coming to the rescue and of course the
ensuing love story.
However,
despite first surface level impressions,
this is not at all what beauty in the
beast is about as it goes down a wholly
different and darker path all together,
thereby namely following the principles
of the Gothic John.
Now it's important that we outlined the
difference between the male and the
female gothic.
The mill variant laid the foundations
for today's horror stories.
Wiles,
the female version became the basis for
today's historical romance stories,
if you will.
Version route generally feature a dark
ass or a mansion style with looming
arches in towers,
a young woman thesis of a dark secret to
uncover who runs away at some point
before she discovers her own power.
A flawed romantic lead who must be
taught how to love a rival or
alternative lead who turns out to be
evil.
And finally a happy ending through a
process of redemption.
Interestingly to sub genre has long been
characterized by kind of schizophrenia
representing the female leads,
inner struggle with personality or
conscious and unconscious fight between
conforming jurors society and breaking
away from it.
So it's not hard to see that this is
exactly a thing that bell attempting to
deal with in her own small town world.
It's a theme that moves her forward and
drives her decision making and really
encompasses the story of beauty and the
beast in its entirety.
In fact,
I would argue that the film in itself is
not so much about finding law in each
other as it is about finding love and
peace in one itself.
Well of course in order for peace to
exist,
there also has to be war.
As the plot is breaking into its fruit,
I climax,
we are exposed to the peak of beauty and
the beast drama,
the final showdown between guest on his
angry mob and the misunderstood beast.
But as exciting and funny as it may be,
to watch the innovating villagers get
ambushed by it,
to be stool servants.
Looking at it from an outside
perspective also makes it undeniably
silly.
I don't get me wrong,
you're probably thinking,
well,
Thomas,
why wouldn't it be?
It's a fairy tale,
and that's exactly right.
It's fantasy.
It's a made up story,
but it's utilized.
You convey a very real message.
One that as is not uncommon for Gothic
novels,
exists on the interior rather than the
exterior because the actual focus of the
story is not really the physical
struggle of Belle and the beast to be
accepted into our world,
but rather the emotional and unconscious
struggle between the animal and human
natures within the protagonists scene
first and the Greek myth of arrows and
CCA,
this archetypal story deals with the
reality of the bodied Ron Nature and
sexual side of humans on the one hand
and the more spiritual,
rational soul on the other centuries
later fairytales,
the big,
the same duality and animal groom tills
in which the animal makes the life of
the female protagonists unpleasant but
ultimately turn out to be gentlemen or
princess in disguise.
This recurring characterised also been
described as the image of the wild man
who's part of an archetypal dialectic
that places wildness along with such
things as Savitri madness,
heresy and hatred and conceptual
antithesis to all things civilization.
Now as we look back at the story of
beauty and the beast is dwell,
the becomes highly apparent.
Being to wild men character and his
story.
Beast identifies of a number of animal
motifs.
The first and most obvious one being his
ugliness and physical appearance,
but more importantly,
it's the realization that is hideous.
Appearance is linked directly to his
ugly personality.
Why isn't she here?
Yet?
We know from the voiceover in the
beginning of the movie that he was
spoiled,
selfish and unkind liking law.
Then his heart,
his inner world is mirror directly to
his surroundings as a showcase by the
constant dark and venue.
Rhetor has ravaged hidden west wing and
the existence of this tool servants
because he who treats his fellow human
beings as tools will ultimately only see
them as such and nothing more as a side
effect of his appearance.
Bese also identifies with the Motif of
captivity.
Not only does he wrongfully imprisoned
marise,
he initially also doesn't feel remorse
for doing the same to bell.
The for a prisoner in his castle then is
himself having drifted into apathy and
rage over his.
Apparently he cursed fate with this
lowly mental state comes his last Motif
nonthinking which just metaphorically
shown here in is repressed.
The ability to
read that I can't.
It's just Ben Guest Oss
is second carrier of the Animal Motif.
Of course,
he starts off as what seems to be the
epitome of perfected humanity with his
handsome looks,
strong physical appearance and
attachment to the freedom motif.
No one says no to guests in reality.
However,
this is only but a facade as he's
covered with hair foreshadows the beast
thickness within his physical beauty.
Gustavo sends a freedom is also strongly
egoic and vindictive as it depends on
its ability to control both animal as
well as human whatever the cost may be
fun.
My wife make no mistake about that.
It's no surprise that his character
mirroring beasts also identifies of non
thinking and even sees it as something
malevolent.
Ooh,
I'm afraid.
I've been thinking dangerous pastime.
I know bell on the other hand is the one
major carrier of the human motif like a
star.
She identifies a beauty which is really
the only thing the villagers compliment
her for.
There she goes,
or oddity marks the second and third.
Once he has it showcases her sense of
individualism and strive for freedom
because although at the moment she's
torn between fitting in and leaving her
provincial life behind.
She finds solace in reading a lot.
This one,
but you've read it twice.
Film evidently makes no secret about it
that val identify at the thinking with
Eve,
read it and unthinking so much so it at
her entire inner beauty and humanities
seems to originate from the archetypal
stories she has read.
These books have taught her to
archetypes for fighting injustice
against overwhelming odds for seeing
beyond the surface for courage and
strength and once oddities and for
wisdom and decision making and breaking
away from group think.
According to Carl Young,
the absolute strength of these
archetypal stories lies in our function
as pointers to to quote unquote
collective unconscious,
that part of self that mediates between
our consciousness and unconsciousness,
the human and the animalistic with the
goal to guide us towards maturity,
to bridge that internal divide.
We see it in bell.
She's slowly developing and trying to
figure out her own individuality,
her own uniqueness,
but paradoxically does natural process
of individuation is also at the core of
the growing loss of the ability to live
in the present moment,
a loss of sense of oneness in community
and to you.
Borek force of nature as a whole now
have that knowledge in mind,
a new door in to the uniqueness of
beauty and the beast has suddenly
opened,
revealing to us the films function as an
archetypal Meta narrative of sorts.
We can now see how at first be strikes a
deal with his dwell.
He buys scapegoating and and her
awesome eat with me doesn't eat.
We can also see how this method of
victimization has worked for guest on
who was fully identified and content
with his ego until bell comes along,
breaking the fragility of this illusion
and causing guest dawn's humanity to
crumble completely as he slowly descends
into his brutish,
animalistic nature until it ultimately
he destroys him
glee for beasts.
The reverse happens when bell shines a
light on his darker side and invites him
to come to terms with it through axle.
Selflessness and honesty.
Yes,
please.
What happens next is the beginning of
both their transformations as beast
rescues bell from the pack of wolves and
she in turn shoot his honor and
compassion by saving beasts these
actions,
bees to move away from as victimization
and to take self responsibility for the
very first time,
which doesn't go unnoticed.
Now he's
why I didn't see it there before.
And out of bell two is conscious of our
own ignorance.
The seed for their ultimate unification
has been blended.
What follows is a process of growth and
interplay of dwell at ease,
which ends with a dance in which animal
and human are joined together and attack
line of the song.
Let me go skate.
Beauty.
And the beast
is at this point that beast is ready to
make the final step in his
transformation by show of true love,
through a dramatic act of self
sacrifice.
And after having spent some time alone,
bell realizes the same thing as she
kneels down beside the dying beast.
So to spell is finally broken as both
transformations have now been completed.
And so Belle and the beast,
the human and the animal are finally
reunited and reintegrated in coexisting
harmony.
It's an archetypal story that has become
more relevant in today's world than it's
probably ever been.
The upcoming and true search of social
media and in particular dating apps,
f arguably bloated our egos and have
degraded the concept of love and to Amir
and mindless movement off the finger.
We suppress and ignore our anxieties and
our feelings of separateness by
connecting evermore.
Yet a lot of us can't help but feel
meaningless alone.
It really is a continuous struggle until
we choose to stop seeing it as such and
instead face it head on and make it into
a dance.
Hello,
Lee.
Hi,
Miss.
Follow me.
I have no,
a three
for my,
hello.